Film Courage: Mark, advice to people who are
caught in two worlds because the reality of
being here [Los Angeles area] is that may
be the case for a decade, for some people
maybe even more and at some point they will
cross over and they will be hosting their
own parties and for some it may not happen.
Talk about keeping your mind right and keeping
your work ethic right.
Mark Sanderson: Well, that’s difficult.
It’s like training.
I used to run as a runner and that discipline
of that constant was really important.
And I would run no matter what, even if I
was tired.
It’s that same work ethic that you need
for writing because I see so many writers
who say “Huh?”
And it’s difficult, I understand.
I tell some writers that “Oh, I just did
a 10-hour day.”
And they are like “10 hours?”
And I go “I have to because I have an assignment
and it’s due and I have the luxury.
That’s my job, thank goodness.
Now when I had a day job only once in my life
for 2 years, I worked at a law firm.
I had to come home from a full day of work
(I was an assistant) and at 6 o’clock make
dinner and then write until midnight.
And then go to bed, 7 a.m. go to that job.
It was having 2 jobs at once and then on the
weekends people would say “Oh, come on…do
this and that.”
And I’d say “Well, I have to write.”
“Write?
What are you talking about?”
And I’d say “Well…”
And it was terribly exhausting and I can see
how it would chip away at you, especially
if you have a family and a lot of different
concerns pulling at you.
That’s why you have to really close the
door and say “This is my time.”
And it cannot be interrupted.
It is hard to do but you really have to stay
disciplined and also I think you have to have
the fire and burning passion to really want
it more than anything else.
Because I never put an expiration date on
my dreams.
And I remember people saying…I was at dinner
one time and a friend of my brother’s said
“Well, what if you don’t make it by 30?”
And I was like “30?”
And I said “Well, I don’t know.
What’s 30?”
And to him he was projecting his fear upon
me and I go “This is open ended, you know?”
I’m sorry because it’s good and bad because
you don’t want to fool yourself like you
are saying, where after 10 years and you have
nothing.
I mean I think after a certain point if you’ve
really exhausted all of your abilities and
nothing has happened, you might consider something…maybe
writing is not for you?
Maybe this pursuit of a career is not for
you?
And it’s a choice and no one is forcing
you to write screenplays.
It’s a dream.
It was my dream since I was 11 years old.
So am I going to achieve it?
Am I going to achieve it at a level that I
want?
Because when I worked in the restaurant while
I was going to film school, I knew people
that were actors who said “Well, it’s
not worth it for me if I’m not like Brad
Pitt.”
And I said “Oh, really?
So you think you’re just going to fall into
it and be A-list?”
Now most working actors or the co-star character
actors work all their lives.
The leading person, the leading man, leading
woman have to carry the film and how many…I
mean, I’m sorry you look at it and plus
as you get older you look at it differently
and you say “Well, I’m blessed to get
up in the morning and do what I love for a
living and get paid for it and see it end
up somewhere and people respond to it negatively
or positively.”
That’s it.
Yes, continue to strive for more and other
projects and different things but it’s hard
and the important thing too is to have people
around you that support your endeavor because
I’ve lost friendships and relationships
with people who said “Well…”
And they drew a line in the sand.
And they said…And I was like that’s not
a good thing to do and what about the last
X number of years I’ve been doing this?
You’re just going to have me throw that
away?
You know, the lack of understanding about
how much filmmaking and writing was such a
part of my being almost like that of other
creative endeavors like drawing and things
like that.
But this is like who I am and to have someone
with you not understand that it’s really…and
that’s the hardest part that so many elements
(just like in making a film), so many elements
have to go together and click.
The same way with forging a career and as
you’ve interviewed many different people,
everybody will tell you a different story
about how they “made it.”
I was doing a seminar recently and someone
asked the question about making it and I said
“Well, I think I don’t know if you ever
make it?”
I think getting your next job is making it
and continuing to stay in the game is making
it.
There’s nothing guaranteed.
If you’re on a TV show, the show is going
to end.
And then you have to get up and we’re like
gypsies.
Find another job.
I have a movie shooting right now in Los Angeles.
When that ends, I mean luckily I have a few
things already going (set up) job wise, you
have to find your next job.
It’s just the case.
It’s difficult but no one said it was going
to be easy.
Film Courage: Before we wrap up on this topic,
I just want to ask, going back to that day
that you’re working this shift at wherever
it was, the top of Mulholland Drive or wherever
it was…
Mark Sanderson: Beverly Hills…
Film Courage: Beverly Hills…okay.
And let’s suppose you’ve broken down the
event and you’re driving down this mountain
or wherever or maybe not a mountain [in Beverly
Hills], what’s going through your mind?
Your name is in Variety on this day.
Mark Sanderson: Well, I stopped at the newsstand
before the job and picked up a pile of Varieties,
you know because you have to.
And reread it and I wasn’t on the cover,
the company was on the cover, but I was on
like page 13 with a paragraph on how they
discovered me.
It’s so nice to be discovered and I’m
here pouring coffee for these people.
It was freak…there was a fear that somehow
it was a big fraud and it was never going
to happen even though…it was terrible.
It was hard to really lock in and then you
get home and it’s very depressing.
You’re like there’s no crowd cheering,
there’s no one like “Wow!”
But then being pragmatic and saying “Well,
I have to pay bills.”
And there’s no embarrassment about doing
a job that you have to do because that job
allowed me to continue to stay in the game.
Now yes, the movie was optioned and as movie
options go there’s not a lot of money sometimes
and then the movie developed 18 months, it
was in development with me.
So you’re talking about it was 7 years after
I wrote it.
So it took 7 years from when I finished it
to when I finally found the company and it
was made.
Not all scripts happen that way.
But I’m talking about a spec and so this
is a long process with a lot of fear that
can be involved.
I always look back on these stories but not
at that time maybe and say “This will be
a good story for the book someday.”
Or to tell someone how these things happen.
There’s a reason why I think we go through
everything is to learn something.
And if we do, maybe pay it forward and that’s
kind of my reasoning for the book [A Screenwriter’s
Journey to Success: Tips, tricks and tactics
to survive as a working screenwriter in Hollywood]
is to try to pay it forward and saying I went
through all these crazy knocks and these pitfalls
and you will, too.
Maybe more, maybe less.
But maybe if you zig and zag, it will help
you a little easier.
But it’s all difficult for all of us because
we also have to sit in front of the blank
page.
That’s where we are equals as screenwriters.